[Music]
and welcome back to chess openings
explained as always my name is caleb
denby
and today i am taking you through
another line in the
f3 nimzo indian we have wrapped up
all of the time we're gonna spend on
this move d5 by black
in my opinion most of the time it's not
a great move
although there are a few lines where
black can equalize there as
we talked about now i'm going to move on
to a rather perplexing fourth move
that many of you may face a little bit
more rarely
in the f3 nimzo so let's jump right into
it the move
is four king side castles and you're
going to arrive there
by the normal move order d4 knight f6 c4
e6 knight c3 bishop e4 f3
and here black is going to castle and if
you guys were paying attention in the
first lectures you might remember this
move
because this was one of the ways black
could arrive at this idea
of playing the move d5 and then we would
be back in those lines that we've talked
about
however you know while i was sort of
trash talking
this move order in order to get to d5
the move for
kingside castles is actually a very well
respected line
however they normally don't combine it
with this move d5
at the top level so what's the idea of
four
king side castles well black is simply
getting the king out of the center
not committing these pawns to either c5
or d5 and now black's next move
is actually going to be with the king's
side knight and believe it or not
there are actually two different options
here but i can go knight
h5 which is going to be the main focus
of this lecture
and then black can also go knight e8 and
while these two moves
may not seem like the most testing
of the f3 nimzo indian we'll come to
find out that these are actually
some of the most combative lines in the
entire uh
in the entire opening so as i said we're
going to mainly focus on knight h5
tonight
and if we have some extra time i'll
begin discussing 98
but let's start with this move in our
main game here between
shakhma manyarov and sergey fetterchuk
um so in the game what is the point of
knight h5 well it very directly
is stopping white's next move and what
is white's next move well white wants to
play the move
e4 of course um and
this of course would be a little bit bit
of a mistake in light of queen to h4
check when after the king moves or pawn
to g3
the knight is coming to g3 regardless
and thanks to this pin
white is simply going to be losing in
this case
so net h5 is a direct attempt to stop
the move e4
so what can white do in response to this
well i think you already saw me
highlight the move
knight h3 and i think this is going to
be white's best move in the position
simply defending against the threat of
queen h4
also preparing to guard some of these
dark squares
number one and secondly to bring this
knight back to f2 where we can come back
to support this pawn to e4 push
now if black were to try this move queen
h4 we are
ready to respond either with g3 or the
simple move
knight f2 when knight g3 no longer works
because our rook is actually going to be
defended
and here this would just be a simple
mistake by black
this queen doesn't belong on h4 and
eventually the queen is going to have to
return
back to its starting square black is
just busy
losing time here both g3 and knight f2
very good for white
so what is the point of this knight h5
move is it just a mistake in light of
knight h3 the queen h4 idea
is not a good one for black so what is
black's point
well black is as we said
focusing on stopping e4 in some very
creative ways here
and the point of this knight h5 move is
to follow it up with this move
of f5 and f5 of course
is only playable because we did get this
knight out of the way on
f6 and i've had some people tell me that
this
is a very tough line for white to crack
there are a few main moves here the move
e4 can be played anyways
bishop g5 is actually the most common
you'll see a lot of players play e3 as
well just sort of biting their
time waiting to play e4 before they get
developed
but i think white's best line is
actually the simple move
knight back to f2 and i'll get into why
i think this is the best
line in a moment notably in regards to
e4
uh if you play it immediately after f
takes e4
it's actually a little bit awkward for
white to try to take this pawn back
because again queen h4 check is going to
start becoming a legitimate threat
e4 is simply hanging of course and
knight f2
is now unplayable looks pretty tough on
all regards king d2 is playable
this is not capturable because the
knight is hanging but this is of course
a bad position
for white so after f takes e4
white is not able to recapture the pawn
directly you have to insert a move like
bishop g5
before recapturing and
initially this position may look quite
favorable to white you have this knight
sort of stranded on the side of the
board
you have an extra piece developed but
the fact of the matter is
i think white is in a little bit of
danger of actually being
worse whenever you have this slightly
strange pawn structure in the center
it's actually going to be black who has
some targets if you imagine a few moves
i'm not saying these are are the best
moves but if you imagine that the
structure would change
in this manner white plays some move
like bishop e2
knight f6 knight f2 say b6
white gets castled you can easily
imagine that a6
is going to be a big weakness black is
able
to occupy the c5 square and it's going
to be black who has all the targets in
the position and i think if the game
were to develop along these lines
white would simply be much worse so
what's the big deal
how is white going to be able to combat
this idea
well i think it all starts with this
move knight f2 which is actually the
fourth most common move but it has been
played by some very good players
the likes of which are you know wesley
so and shock mohammed yarov
amongst some some very good other
players as well
so what's the point of knight f2 well
we'll see in the game
footer shook plays knight to c6 and now
white does play this
move e4 uh now in the game
we actually don't see f takes e4
immediately it could have been played
here
um but maybe we'll see what uh
mamadyarov's idea is a little bit later
on in the game
instead we see uh e4 d6 by fettershook
delaying the capture
for a few moments bishop d3 by shaak
mahmud yarov
and now after f takes e4 we don't
actually see shock
recapturing with the f pawn which is
probably the most natural to most of you
you know of course this is why we play
f3 to control the e4 square
but once again this structure is going
to end up favoring black in the long run
if white isn't very accurate
and so to avoid this sort of structural
weakness we actually see shock
capturing with a piece on e4 and this is
the main idea behind this move
knight f2 it's to capture on the e4
square
with a piece and not a pawn now why is
this so much better
well because it gives white a very clear
line of active play
in this case we're going to see white
actually take with the bishop because if
you take what the knight
e5 might immediately be making a threat
whereas when we take with the bishop
after e5 we have this pawn well defended
already so that's the
little subtlety there by shock just
making sure he doesn't lose the tempo
to e5 after capturing so bishop takes e4
was played in the game
and now we do see that black admits this
knight is misplaced and brings it back
to f6 by the way i want to take this
opportunity to discuss the move
knight f4 it's sort of been lurking in
the air for a few turns now
black could have played it at a few
different moments but what do you think
the response
to knight f4 is going to be in this case
and i'll ask
the chatroom this one what are we doing
about knight f4
what's the point
what is the point
anybody in the chat room know the points
should probably refresh
yes i should have refreshed g3 has been
suggested castles has been suggested
so in this case both of those moves are
going to be good but there is a very
very surprising move
that is also going to be very good for
white and we'll see why in a little bit
but that move i wanted to suggest is the
move bishop takes
f4 and this is going to move that looks
horribly unnatural to many of you it
looks sort of anti-positional
to give away your bishop pair in this
manner but
as we'll see in the game white's play
really is coming along this diagonal and
i think
in this particular variation it's going
to lead to an advantage
for white to play on this diagonal and
so i want you guys
to keep this idea in mind bishop takes
f4 looks entirely unnatural at least to
my eyes
but it does turn out to be a very good
move in many cases
because it loosens it weakens black's
control over these king side light
squares
and that's what's going to make the
difference in this game so
in this particular instance though
castles and g3 are both great moves
i would advise a little bit of caution
whenever you play g3
as it does weaken some squares around
your own king a little bit which i want
to talk about in a moment
but ignoring it in this case is
perfectly fine
but that's with the caveat that actually
if you just castle here you're probably
going to end up capturing this knight
in just a few turns anyways
but knight f4 not played in the game
instead federer shook chose
knight back to f6 hitting this bishop of
course
our play is on this diagonal that's why
we captured with a piece on e4
so white saves the bishop bishop c2
and now black's task is to find a way
to get some active counter play here
so what is going to be the idea for
active counter play in this case
well uh against this structure all of
these four king
side castle lines really have the same
idea for getting counter play
number one you sort of take over the
dark squares with the move like e5
and number two you start to target this
pawn on c4 this is the main idea for
black to achieve counter play
so in this game we're going to see that
shocks play on this diagonal
is actually simply coming far too
quickly for black to handle
and so this counterplay doesn't really
matter but then we're going to see
another
few examples where black sort sort of
goes after this directly
and what you can do to sort of combat
that
so let's take a look bishop c2 played on
the game and federshirk goes e5
in this case mamadiarov takes the
opportunity
to castle king side and now we do in
fact see
b6 by black probably with this idea
in mind now remember when i said
knight f4 and bishop takes f4 was a
perfectly reasonable
idea well shock sort of proves that
point here by playing the move bishop g5
he's not afraid of trading this bishop
for the night with the idea of
weakening this king side structure for
black
black plays h6 and we're not going to
see the immediate capture the immediate
capture actually is possible and
probably good
but simply bishop h4 queen e8
was federshuk's idea and now queen d3
and we're beginning to see
shock's idea sort of develop in the game
black really only had one move at this
point to still stay in the fight here
and that move was 97 with the idea of
going for a quick
bishop f5 and white could do a number of
things here
including simply g4 trying to stop this
idea and renew the threats
including taking this knight on f6
including taking on e5
including playing the move c5 really
white could play anything here and have
a bit of an edge
but in the game black actually blundered
immediately with
queen f7 which is simply losing to this
king's side attack
shock found the best way forward playing
knight g4 again
removing this piece from the defense of
the king side
knight e7 was played but now it's just a
bit too late for this idea
bishop takes f6 again giving up the
bishop
to remove the light square defender
bishop f5
queen d2 um and here black actually just
just resigns on move
19. so this was quite the uh the
miniature here
and in fact it is going to be quite
relevant to our opening theory
of course black messed up a few points
at a few points along the way
but i wanted to start with this game to
really highlight uh one of white's main
plans and i think this
is the best plan for white to go for in
the majority
of cases that we're going to look at so
let's jump through it one more time and
see what happened we add
of course the opening moves to the nimzo
indian this kingside castles move a3
takes takes now knight h5 by black
and knight h3 is our response f5 to stop
e4 we go knight f2 knight c6
and e4 and again my point is
that many times after f takes e4 we're
actually going to reply to this
with the move knight takes e4 um
and if f takes e4 had been played
immediately i do think i'm gonna
recommend
the move knight takes e4 i should
mention that this has literally never
been played f takes e4 here
so it's a bit silly to call it part of
the opening theory
but i am gonna say i like this idea for
white
sort of the best and play will likely
continue how we saw it continue in the
game
with this bishop coming to d3 e5
happening
bishop c2 to defend the pawn castles and
white launching a a king side attack
but of course in the game takes wasn't
immediately played d6 first
bishop d3 takes takes knight f6 bishop
back to c2
e5 castles and here i think
b6 is sort of sort of the beginning of
the end
for black i should say again black
wanted to find active counter play on
the queen side
but the the king side was just a bit too
weak for this sort of counter play to
work
what could black do instead well it
turns out that the slightly ugly looking
idea
may be to put this pawn on d5 for
example takes takes
and d5 and white is again i think going
to be a bit
better in this case but uh black is is
in there with a fight you know fighting
back for some of these central squares
and black is going to be able to help
defend the king a bit more in this case
without getting so sort of rolled over
in the center of the board
with that in mind there are some other
ideas for black as well
for example all of these lines that i'm
talking about in this first game
involve black capturing on e4 and
opening up this center
of course this is not something black is
forced to do and so we're going to
examine the case
of when black sort of leaves this pawn
in
tension for a little bit and then
eventually plays this move f4 this is
another
very important idea to keep in mind here
for
black but first questions on this
particular line where black is capturing
on e4
and i'm going to recommend in the
majority of cases you take
on e4 with a piece and we're going to
see a little bit later in the lecture
this isn't always the case sometimes
depending on how the game has gone
it is going to be a good idea to take
this back with the pawn
but our main idea with this knight f2
move is going to be
to recapture on e4 with the piece all
right questions here though
questions here
what if queen h4 after 94
i will get to mentioning that as well
actually but that's a good question
in this particular situation where we're
taking with the bishop of course
if here uh takes takes queen h4
the idea is going to be to go g3 and the
queen just
simply has to retreat and will develop
as normal and we'll see a slight
improvement for black if
black does want to go for this idea
and what white should do in response
patrick has a general question what
happens when your opponents work to get
out of theory instantly
well i should mention that e4 here um
this exact position with knight f2
has only been played 22 times in in
history right
like this line isn't the most i okay i
should amend that not
in history it appears 22 times in the
database of title players that i'm
i'm working with here so this knight f2
line is a bit of a sideline and so it's
a little bit of a stretch
to call this stuff you know heavily
theory based that's why i'm focusing on
the idea of knight f2
being to capture on e4 with the piece
and use this
open diagonal to your advantage and i
should say while this
knight h5 move might be you know
qualified as a bit of a sideline
it's got some some title recognition
behind it i should say
because some very strong players have
played this line and it's something that
i have actually faced
quite a bit uh in my series chess games
what about g4 here g4 i think is an idea
that they sometimes do combined with
this move of e3
and to be honest with you i i don't
think any of these lines are are ever
very good
for um for for whites
i'm struggling to come up with the exact
position where i was looking at it
but yeah g4 is just not
not going to be the ticket here it's a
little too weakening
of your king side all right let us
move on uh why doesn't white first play
bishop g5 and then knight f2
well bishop g5 is actually the most
common move here and this is perfectly
playable
but i actually think that you improve
black's queen
by playing this move bishop g5 now in
many cases where black
you know has taken we take with a piece
they play e5 and take here
we're gonna be dealing with the queen
sitting directly opposite
our king and yeah this is actually the
line where they go g4
and i simply don't like this from white
whenever you're playing against a
sideline
it is tempting to go sort of wild in
your um
in your preparation and prepare a line
like bishop g5 and g4
but i think it's a little bit
unnecessary and the reason for that
is that when it is a little bit uh less
common of a line
the the fact of the matter tends to be
that your opponent is going to be more
prepared for you
than you u in the ensuing complications
and i should mention
i don't even think this line is that
good for white i think black equalizes
without too many difficulties here
due to the weaknesses created by this
move g4
so yeah bishop g5 is a playable move if
that's the route you want to go
i am recommending this move knight f2
because i think it gives white a simple
nice
small edge that can very very quickly
turn into a big edge as we saw in this
game
but let us move on from this idea now so
this game shows uh how the game is
likely going to develop
if you do face an f takes e4 at some
moment
black is going to try to get counter
play on the dark squares and with
something like this
and white is simply going to castle
king's side and look
to target the weak light squares on
black's king's side
but let us move on to game number two
which is going to be
between two english chess legends
of course english either number one or
number two he bounces back and forth
with david howe a little bit
talking about gawain jones and of course
the ever famous lawrence trent they
had a game in this exact line and it was
quite an instructive one
so i wanted to take a look at it here
and what this
uh what idea this game is going to show
is going to be
again what i talked about if black isn't
playing this move
f takes e4 let's just get to our
position here
takes takes knight h5 knight h3
f5 knight f2 once again is gawain
jones's choice
here we see the move uh d6 once again
e4 and now rather than the move
well sorry d6 is the new move again in
the previous game we saw knight c6
d6 is a bit more common but nothing too
crazy
e4 and now lawrence trent chooses this
move
queen to e8 so of course now
black leaves these pawn these pawns in
tension a little bit longer
again our move here is going to be
bishop d3
with the idea of recapturing on e4
not necessarily with the pawn but either
with the bishop or the knight
leaving this diagonal open so we can
achieve some play
on this diagonal rather than have a
silly looking bishop
stuck behind the pawn against the move
e5
so bishop d3 played in the game and then
lawrence trent goes e5
not necessarily taking on e4 and opening
up this diagonal
now white is met with a choice this
position has actually occurred
a couple times and one of the games
between
two 2600s you saw we saw the move e
takes f5b played but this didn't lead to
much for white in fact i think white got
into a little bit of trouble
with the king in the center so i like
the wayne jones move the simple
castles what's the downside to this move
well now lawrence trent is able to block
up the center
with the move f4 and
this is going to be an idea you have to
look out for i think the the move order
that lawrence trent chose was a pretty
good one
but just as an fyi i know for a fact
i've played some games where black is
just playing f4 here
immediately after e4 and here the ideas
are just going to largely
be be the same as in the game
so in the game though queen e8 bishop d3
e5 castles and
and then f4 why do i think this move
order is better by lawrence trent
well this queen is well placed on e8 in
my opinion
and this bishop is perhaps sub-optimally
placed if this diagonal isn't actually
opening
so i think this is a better version for
black than the immediate f4
that's that's what i'm trying to say
so chat room how do you want to approach
this position
does the chat have any ideas of what
white should be doing against this move
f4
and pippinchuk has uh phrased
his answer in the form of a question
perhaps in memory of the great alex
trebek
and he says after black plays f4 why
doesn't white
play c5 and in fact his question is the
answer
as i said this move c5 is actually going
to be a great idea
for white in this position what is the
point well the point is this pawn on c4
is sort of useless if white were to play
a bad move
like the move d5 then these pawns are
really just stepping on each other's
toes
and white is going to be significantly
worse so white shouldn't be afraid to
gambit this pawn with the move c5
opening up some diagonals and starting
to challenge
black's big pawn chain and let me
reiterate if there's one thing you
shouldn't do
in this position it's play the move d5
this just allows black to get a total
bind on the position and in the long run
you're likely going to get checkmated in
classical king's indian style for
example
let's just give black a few moves let's
say black gets a setup looking
something like this bishop c2
um knight f6 g5
h5 this is white's future and you might
think it's a little bit
silly to uh you know give black all
these moves
but the fact of the matter is i
challenge you to find an active plan for
white
after this move uh d5 and let's say b6
first just just stopping c5
and i don't think you're going to come
up with one this is just going to be
really really tough to deal with
so in these positions uh don't sort of
take them lightly
white's position is actually very much
in danger of becoming worse
if you play a few nonchalant moves right
these ideas
come reasonably quickly as well as b6
for for black so c5 you must play
actively
whenever black tries to shut down this
center you can't take your time with
these things
lawrence plays the most combative moves
here and takes on c5
and gawain jones follows up with queen
b3 check
now if bishop e6 of course there's a
problem on
b7 something like queen e6 bishop c4 is
a problem
so king h8 must be played and
here gawain jones plays a pretty
interesting move
he plays the move a4 and what's the
point the point
is to activate this bishop potentially
along this diagonal and also to meet
something with
like b6 with an eventual move like a5
and this is the problem with black
playing this way
with e5 f4 white is actually just going
to be able
to rip open the queen side immediately
and ensure that it's not going to turn
to the
into this checkmating race like a normal
king's indian black is going to have to
meet white
on the queen side because the play is
just coming a bit too quickly
with that in mind though lawrence of
course did not resign the game after a4
he plays the move b6 trying to shore up
his queen side a little bit
but it's it's worth noting how far away
this
seemingly you know distant pipe dream of
playing g5 h5 g4
really is black simply does not have the
time to play like this
this bishop is coming to a3 this pawn is
coming under fire
and white is going to have a lot of
active play here for example something
like knight bd7
is perfectly playable but when you face
it with
d take c5 you start to realize already
there are too many threats over here to
ignore
so something like c6 rook fd1 and white
is just going to be the more
active side in this case so lawrence
immediately meets going on the queen
side with the move b6
and we do see d take c5 by white
don't get too attached to having some
sort of massive center here
your play is on the queen side now that
the center is closed
again it does you absolutely no good to
play the move d5
this is going to be a huge mistake
shutting off your active diagonal
shutting off any play in the d file and
sort of once again
giving black a free hand on the king's
side
so d takes c5 great move by gawain
bishop e6
and here uh perhaps it would have been a
bit more accurate for gwan to keep the
bishops on the board
and just move this queen something like
queen b1 queen b4
queen b5 even but uh instead gawain
chooses bishop c4
which is fine for white we see takes
takes queen f7
queen d5 is his choice and now after
queen takes d5
e takes d5 knight f6 bishop a3
with some threats rookie 8 and c4
i sort of blazed through those last few
moves
but the fact of the matter is uh white
succeeded
in um changing you know the the feel of
the game
black with f4 was threatening to turn it
into a very one-sided battle
with the queen side locked up and a
checkmating race on the king's side
and instead gawain jones took control of
the game
immediately and diverted all the
attention to the queen side
where white is going to have some edge
due to the spatial advantage
so that is the way to play in
this particular against this particular
idea of locking down the center
b take c5 was uh lauren's trend's choice
and now
rook b1 is accurate and good just
activating this rick immediately
knight a6 knight d3 and it's clear that
black is going to be dealing with these
weaknesses
for the rest of the game and eventually
gawain does go on
to win this game thanks to these active
pieces and this myriad
of weaknesses that black is having to
deal with here
so i won't show you any more of this
game just quickly scrolling through a
few moves you see
he gets this nice rook on b5 and just
all of his pieces
actively placed all of black's pieces
passively placed it's just
a dream position eventually taking on e5
and
winning a nice bishop versus knight end
game
with a powerful a pawn that's simply
impossible to stop
um so what happened this game let us
review one more time
we see now this idea again knight f2
e4 again our point is to capture back
with a piece on the e4 square
queen e8 e5 and f4 is lawrence trent's
idea
locking down the center and you see
immediately
that white goes for this idea of c5
immediately opening up
the diagonal challenging these dark
squares challenging
the queen side that's the way you have
to play
um in order to counteract this f4 idea
so let's talk about a couple caveats
here because of course black doesn't
have to play
exactly like lawrence trent played so
let's say
once again black immediately goes with
this move
f4 i think again bishop d3 is a
perfectly fine move
let's say e5 and castles
getting developed and then let's say
black plays something a little bit more
tenacious like the move
b6 trying to guard c5 what do you think
the right idea is going to be here for
white
against this idea of b6 what do you
think
chat what do you think
and yeah of course the idea is not to
give up on the c5 idea
you simply play it anyways it's still
going to be correct it's the same
principle
whether or not it ends up being upon
sacrifice is sort of irrelevant
right we're not really worried about
this extra pawn for black
it's all about active play on the
queen's side chatroom is spot
on with this one so
that's all there really is to say on on
this idea here
basically e5 f4 c5 is a crucial crucial
break
to keep in mind and that is sort of
the the story to be had uh the story to
be had there
and i should say you can even play c5 as
early as the move after f4 is played
i do want to mention that i would advise
castling the king first in many cases
but this is sort of just to show you can
even play c5 here and it's not a bad
idea so with all that in mind
any other questions on e5 f4
okay
what if black played c5 before white
well we'll talk about that one as well
but not in this game i am going to
mention an early c5
uh if you play something like c5 here i
should say again
castles is going to be fine let's say e5
and there's just too much just to sort
of hold together here
for black let's say
you try let's say this move order
um and okay i i should say that's
probably bishop e2 is a better move
against the immediate f4 so i'm going to
stop putting this bishop on d3
again this is why i think lawrence
trent's move order is the best
by drawing this bishop to d3 and only
then going for this idea
so let's say f4 the media bishop e2
let's say e5
and kingside castles and c5
so what's going to be the idea here chat
what's going to be the idea here
white to move and actually nearly win
the game
nearly win the game and yet uh chess
king has the right idea you
you want to take one of these pawns uh a
huge source of play is not only
the queen side but the open d file again
the worst move in the position is d5
you know even moves that hang pieces i
would rather see you know if i were
teaching someone i would rather see them
play bishop e3 than d5 that's how much i
hate this move but
d take c5 or c5 takes back and queen d5
is just going to be very very powerful
takes takes
and now with queen's off the board white
has a protected passer
still has counter play on the queen side
white is simply positionally winning
in this case so this is a good point to
mention though if you see the premature
f5 i do recommend putting the bishop
on e2 rather than on the d3 square to
keep the d
file open uh and again that's why i
think this move order by lawrence trent
is pretty clever drawing the bishop to
d3 first and then putting the pawn on
f4 okay let us move on then
so as i said our idea of playing knight
f2
is often times to take on e4
with uh with the knight
is knight g5 a blunder yeah knight g5
just doesn't make sense it's just going
to get pushed away
and then there's no reason to put this
knight here
but as i said often times our idea with
knight f2 is to take on e4 with that
being said
there are of course going to be
exceptions to this so i want to take a
look at one of those exceptions
from a pretty high profile game between
the one and only
wesley so against dania daniel
naraditsky
and these players actually met in the
2015
united states championship so this was a
high level game
and i think donya didn't do as much
studying on this line as he
should have because wesley so sort of
took him to town on this one and let's
see what happened
so we start with our same opening moves
we get f3 castles a3 takes takes
and knight h5 knight h3 f5
and again knight f2 is wesley's idea
here
and now we've seen two moves that
directly influence the center
by black we've seen d6 and we've seen
knight c6 and the idea of both
is to eventually play this move e5 and
start fighting back for some of these
squares
in the center that being said i did say
that white's main source of counterplay
in the first game if you remember
in let's say a position like this
is going to be going after this pawn on
c4
this is a very common source of counter
play for black in these positions
now let's see what happens if black
tries to go for that counter play
immediately with the move b6
well wesley still continues with the
move e4
and here dania plays the move f takes e4
and interestingly knight takes e4 still
a
perfectly fine move for white i should
say that off the bat
knight takes e4 not bad here at all i
think probably
slight edge to white with the move
knight takes e4
but in this particular instance black
has played a move that does
nothing to influence the center and
because of that
white is simply close to winning after
the move f takes e4
so what do we mean by that well f takes
c4 is of course the more combative move
when compared to knight takes e4 why is
that
well you're simply threatening to take
away this knight's only retreating
square
and if you succeed in doing that this
knight in h5 is going to be a very very
bad piece
and this is what happened in the game
and wesley so was
was simply close to winning out of the
opening in this case
uh dania went queen to f6
trying to attack f2 and get some
tactical threats going
and wesley plays the cool the calm the
collected
rook a2 defending laterally i love this
move
um queen f7 by donia trying to give the
knight this square
now knight h3 comes by wesley so
and the hits are going to keep coming
here if you think you're going to get
away
with knight to uh to f6 think again
these moves start coming these moves
start coming these moves start coming
in the game daniel plays queen g6 trying
to pressure this
now e5 is taking away this square and it
really is
just losing for for black at this point
um bishop b7 was played and perhaps the
best move
for white here is rook f2 but what
wesley did was enough for an advantage
he goes bishop d3 and you can see now
that white is sort of just crushing
inactivity
on the king's side here doesn't really
matter that the king stuck in the center
white is just much much better so bishop
b4 was played
and they went down this forcing line
queen b1 queen c2
takes takes black succeeds and getting
rid of some of these active white pieces
but is just left with the worst position
the game continued with g6 knight g5
knight over to e4 g4 and again this
knight is a bit stuck
knight f4 bishop e3 knight h3
rook g2 knight f4 and i don't want to
get too into the nitty-gritty here
but basically donya felt the need to
sacrifice this pawn
and the game did actually get
interesting again but the point was
at this moment in the opening it's very
very clear
that uh that black is is pretty close to
lost here this is just
a pretty bad position for black and
probably again wesley had other ways to
continue without trading the queens
going for a smaller advantage something
like rookie 2 would have been great
with again the idea to do this and get
the king safe
but the point of the matter is just
because our idea is knight takes e4
doesn't mean f takes e4 is always going
to be bad and in fact i think this is
going to be
a pretty good move in the case that
black has
wasted time and done nothing to
influence the center
for example with a move like b6 other
moves like this
something like a5 if your opponent
played now after e4 if takes
again f takes is going to be really good
and it might seem unrealistic to a
specter move like b6
or a5 but if donya is playing it in the
us championship
i figured it was worth at least briefly
mentioning
so what was the point the point is if
your opponent is wasting time
you can feel free to take on e4 with the
pawn
with the point that you're going to have
some very active play on the queen side
why isn't this move as good after knight
c6 for example well let's take a look
takes takes and
actually i should mention this probably
is good after knight c6
that's why you didn't see uh federer
shook take on e4 immediately
in game one and why isn't this good
after for example
d6 uh fe4 fe4
well now e5 is going to be more
difficult to achieve with black already
contesting this square that's why the
move b6 is what really allowed wesley to
go a little bit wild
in this in this case
okay so questions on this
idea before i show you a slightly
important maneuver
all right i am just going to move along
i've been answering too many questions
all right so what's this important
maneuver i'm talking about well i'm just
going to show you from a position
not from any game necessarily but let's
say perhaps
we go down this path that we've been
going down knight h5
knight h3 f5 knight f2 d6
e4 and let's say that black plays the
move
knight f6 what's the point of this move
the point of this move
is to combat our idea of taking on e4
with the piece
by increasing the pressure to this pawn
well play can continue very naturally we
still want to go bishop d3
and after fe4 i still stand by this move
knight takes e4 i think this is fine for
white
knight takes e4 bishop takes e4 and
black hasn't really stopped our idea
in fact black has already traded off
this defender on
f6 however now this idea of queen h4
check
does become sort of a reality here why
is it good here when it wasn't good
before
well the point now is that our knight on
f2 is missing and after g3
this queen is actually able to come into
h3 and start creating threats
so there's a very important maneuver
that i wanted to at least mention if you
find yourself
facing this or any similar situations
when you're taking on e4
with the knight so chat room what do you
think white should be playing here give
me white's next
three moves to evict this queen
give me white's next three moves
king f2 so king f2 is not gonna not
gonna be it in this case it's a little
bit too much to be playing king f2
what's wrong with king f2 well
i mean maybe it's playable but i i i
just wouldn't would rather not um this
knight is probably coming here
and here and here and you you've got
some problems
got some problems there's a much better
way to uh to get rid of it
so yeah you guys are starting to hit
upon the idea here
you want to get this bishop back to this
diagonal and i think the best way to do
it
is to start with this move queen e2 you
don't let this queen
into g2 and the point now is that after
uh white gets developed or black gets
developed something like knight c6
you're actually going to play the move
f4 and bishop g2
castles is coming pretty much
unstoppably next
and this is going to be the idea for
white that i'm recommending
here for example the game could continue
something like bishop d7
bishop g2 queen f5 castles does this
mean we've given up on our idea of
counter play
along this diagonal not at all we've
just delayed it slightly to castle our
king
bishop e4 and bishop d3 with queen e4
ideas to follow
are definitely still in the air along
with ideas of applying some pressure
down these open central files so i
wanted to mention this idea
at least i think this is an important
maneuver to keep in mind to get this
queen
out of your territory um what happens if
black plays the move e5 here
trying to stop um f4 this is a perfectly
reasonable question
and i think the matter the fact of the
matter is without the queen
in the center uh white can start to look
to open things up a little bit
something like d takes e5 something like
bishop d5 check
something like bishop g5 and this pawn
is going to be a little bit of a
weakness
for um for black i'm not saying white
has some sort of huge advantage in this
position
i'm just saying white has a target here
and eventually
you can play something like queen f1 and
something like queen g2 for example to
evict this queen out of your territory
and end up castling
as well so e5
may be a good idea for black but you can
take give black a little bit of a
weakness and
play with the bishops on an open board
what more can you really ask for um
so aside from that i do want to mention
if that
type of position isn't really your cup
of tea there is one more idea here for
white
i don't really like f takes e4 because
again i think after e5
white is in a little bit of danger of
becoming worse off these positions in my
experience are just very hard to play
practically
but the move bishop c2 is actually going
to be a good one for
white point is e takes f queen takes f3
e5 castles and white just plays the
position
upon down the ideas are going to remain
largely the same
but white has sacrificed upon for a
little bit of extra time
castling the king and developing the
pieces so this is also perfectly
playable
for white
okay so what was the point the point was
that we are playing e4 with knight f2
and taking
with a piece if black tries some um
some line like knight f6 trying to make
this difficult we develop anyways
and we can take take take and queen h4
check isn't so scary
when we come up with this idea of queen
e2 following up with bishop g2
in order to evict this queen from our
territory and
get castled okay other questions
other questions
ah does black have anything that is easy
to play for black and hard to play for
white in the f3 nimzo all the variations
seem like white has an easy position to
play well that's the point
that's the point of the lecture series
white is killing it in all the
variations
white is killing it however i have sort
of been avoiding the
white whale of the f3 nimzo which is the
move 4c5 so
those lines just as a heads up they're
going to get a little complicated it's
difficult to play
sort of simple natural moves and and be
doing well
but i do think white has good chances in
those lanes as well
but if everything is looking too easy so
far wait for those c5 lines it gets
tough
alright so there is one more
idea i want to mention uh
along with this idea of uh
the early knight f6 and that is what if
black plays the move
c5 in this particular position
right we looked at it in a few different
ways where
c5 was never really working for black
because we could take
and place something like queen d5 to
follow but what if black just
comes right out and does it in this
position well
the fact is it's not really going to
change our ideas too much and there is
one
pretty um instructive game between berks
and some random 2300 named berkovic
interesting matchup there between
berks and burkeovich but they just
continued with e4
fe4 and in this case because again black
has not played a move to control the e5
square
white captured on e4 with the pawn and i
think that's a pretty good rule you take
back on e4 with the pawn
if black is doing nothing to control the
e5 square
in that game black played knight f4 and
white played bishop e3
i do want to mention bishop takes f4
again
great move for white in this case
because the the ideas are going to be
largely the same
but the point is black just doesn't
simply have time to combine c5 and f4
and c5 without f4 just doesn't make too
much sense
because black should be focusing more on
controlling the e5 square
all right with all that in mind um i
do want to spend the last 10 minutes
sort of introducing the
idea of knight e8 so this knight h5 idea
it's i think a relatively um newer idea
in that it it sort of was never played
until the past 10 years
but uh it's not the newest idea by any
stretch i think this one is sort of
starting to fade from the limelight as
its
bite has largely been taken out by the
myriad of options that white really has
against it so what's better than that h5
well why not put all your pieces on the
back
rank and that's what i want to talk
about for the last bit of this lecture
so while i switch chapters here knight
e8
what is the point of knight to e 8
well it's a little bit mysterious at
first glance
why black would want to play the move
knight e8 but the point
is simply to start controlling some more
squares
on this um king side a little bit
earlier on and we'll see some some
parallels
why 98 ends up being useful so what's
the point of 98
well the point is you give white
everything you ever wanted you get to
play e4 for free
no knight h5 winning a tempo to play f5
garbage
queen h4 check is nothing here you just
play g3
and so at first glance it's like yeah
this is
fantastic white is doing great
but then you start reading the names of
the people who play like this and you
see like
peter lecko if you ever see that peter
lecko has played a line
you can sort of bet on that line as
being okay for black
just as a general rule of thumb the
point is basically
you go directly after this pawn on c4
from the get-go you waste no time with
black
you're not pretending to stop e4 you're
not pretending to attack on the king's
side
you are coming after this guy and you
are going to take this guy
for example play continue with bishop d3
bishop a6
knight h3 this is the the main line that
i'm recommending
something like knight c6 is the idea for
black
again every move is aimed at the purpose
of attacking c4 castles king side
knight a5 again literally every move at
with the purpose of attacking
c4 queen e2 and now black
should probably follow up with the move
c5
the point being we want to attack this
pawn on c4
one more time and here the line i'm
going to recommend
is still the main line i think um you
know the theoreticians
got this one right uh the main line i
think is the best for white
with the move e5 and now black is sort
of met
with some tough decisions there are a
few different ways the game could go
here and i just wanted to introduce
some of the uh some of the main ideas
so the most common move i think is is
actually going to not be the best
for black so let's start with that what
is the point of e5 well the point is
let's say black passes for example now
you're going to be in a little bit of
danger of getting destroyed on the
king's side
by everybody's favorite greek gift
queen e4 for example g6 queen
h4 and there's there's simply no way to
stop mate
so that's the point of e5 right you got
to look out after e5
because this greek gift is is coming and
it's coming with
a force so black's most popular move
here
is f6 why f6 well you simply want to
stop
knight g5 thereby eliminating this
idea of playing the move bishop takes h7
and here i'm actually going to take a a
page
from my arch nemesis jonathan schrantz
jonathan trans had been doing a lot of
prep for a match against me
involving the f3 nimzo and i myself
have played this line with black in the
past and still often do
to this day and i think that this line
is pretty
is pretty reasonable for black i don't
think black is too much worse but
you know again referring back to my hero
peter lecko who
only plays good openings but um jonathan
came up with a pretty interesting idea
here that i wanted to share with you
so the main line goes with bishop f4 and
this was not jonathan's idea
and after bishop f4 play might continue
c takes d4
c takes d4 and d5 now after d5
you're gonna get e takes d6 by white i
think this is the best idea
otherwise you just get a trade on d3
eliminating a lot of this king's side
pressure
and after this you get a temporary pawn
sacrifice
for black but black is likely going to
regain one of these pawns in the center
of the board
or at least get some very active play
down
the the center of the board with this
rook right
and i think this line is going to be
okay for
black it's very difficult to keep both
of these pawns together
but jonathan's idea was why do you need
bishop f4
i am just going to play the move rook a2
and respond to rook c8 with rook c2
and i think this is a very reasonable
way to continue the game
now after c takes d4 for example white's
point
is that you are simply not going to be
able to take
my pawn on on c4
d5 is still going to be a playable idea
for for black but now
if knight takes d6 queen takes e uh
queen takes on e6 for example
knight back to f7 uh the fact of the
matter is
we don't have this bishop on f4 just yet
but we have this extra defense on uh
our c4 pawn and we have some time for
example to play
rook e1 in this position and what's
going on here
it's sort of anybody's guess we are well
out of any theory that has been um
you know tried over the board by good
players for example queen takes d4
knight f2 is coming and white has the
bishops
black has pressure on the c pawn white
has controlled the e file
it's very much up in the air what's
going on
i am going to talk more on this 98 idea
next week as well as introduce a few
new ideas to the position as well but i
think
that's about where we're going to call
it here for tonight
so with that introduction to 98 once
again chatroom turning it over to any
questions you have
specifically on this idea of knight h5
and also on this introduction to 98 and
again
we're going to get into the nitty-gritty
of knight e8
next week i didn't want to bog you down
with too many you know theoretical lines
because we already did a lot on
knight h5 and that was the main idea for
this lecture
so chatroom questions on tonight's
lecture
question on tonight's lecture questions
on tonight's lecture
why doesn't white play bishop e3 instead
of knight h3
well your idea is to play e4
and i guess your point is to play um
bishop to d2
um i i suppose this is playable but
the point is this knight is not going to
be good on e2 right
it's it's square really is going to be
on f2 and if you play something like e4
here
uh i mean okay
even things like this sort of be become
an idea
right um i think it's not so much that
the bishop
is bad on f2 it's that the knight is bad
if it doesn't have this this f2 square
um why not go king h8 so we're
down deep into the end of this variation
here
i think we're talking about
uh let's see let's say not rookie 2 but
this
d5 sorry take take and then d5
take take take here why not king h8
while this this piece is hanging
and i guess if you're talking about this
line
for example um let's say take take
d5 take take take here king h8
um knight f4 is is sort of coming and
there are a lot of sacrificial ideas
up in the air that you're gonna have to
be a little bit wary of
and that's all even here knight f4 might
still be coming
but the point now is that this is going
to be a bit more of an issue
unveiling the threat of the queen but
again we're going to get more into those
lines next week
but that is going to have to be where i
call it for tonight as
our time is dwindling if you guys are
watching live please head over to the
twitch channel
where we are going to have another
edition of tactics time
um and if you're watching the youtube
video please let me know what you
thought in
those comments thank you guys so much
for watching
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
you